here's kamala harris an article came out
from new york post
where is kamala two weeks since being
named border cesar
harris borders are harry still hasn't
visited
the border president biden named harris
on march 24 to head up the
diplomatic effort to reach out to the
leaders of mexico and central american
countries
about the flood of immigrants a migrant
saying she
speaks for me but so far she has only
phoned guatemalan president alejandro
yamate and mexico's andres manuel lopez
uh
abrador to discuss root causes of the
crisis instead in her first two weeks as
czar she has traveled to connecticut
chicago and home to california over the
easter weekend and has
presided over swearing in ceremonies
touted the administration's coronavirus
stimulus package and covet
response visited the vaccination sites
launched with the press and lunched with
the president attended a cabinet meeting
and held listening sessions
with faith leaders and small business
owners her public schedule showed
asked at the white house briefing
wednesday about when harris might travel
to the border press
secretary jen sackey said
there is no trips on the schedule i
don't have any trips to outline or
preview
what our focus is on is solutions and
ensuring we have more beds we're making
the processing more efficient and
effective and that
we are addressing this in a human way
that keeps these kids as safe as
possibly we can
she said of the surging numbers of
accompanied minors
showing up to the crossing okay at the
crossing so here's one thing look
um say what you want to say about bill
clinton he showed up
say what you want to say about bush he
showed up crisis happened he's there the
next day
say what you want to say about trump he
showed up he showed up
he's like hey what's going on over here
what the hell is going on what even
showing up
you know if this is the kind of a crisis
that we're having right now why don't
you go see for yourself
why don't you go show some support why
don't you go support some of the guys
that don't have the easiest job it's not
the easiest job to be the guy
that's finding the kid that's not an
easy job right now their job at the
border is not an easy job so
u.s okay let's let's see the reason why
people are coming to america is what
because america is still
the greatest country in the world so
people want to come where to america
okay you don't see people coming from
canada down here as much as we got
people from mexico
el salvador are coming up here people
don't go crossing the border from canada
the way they are crossing the border
here that says a lot about canada good
for canada for being a neighboring
country mexico a different story can you
really influence politically making
these calls
i don't know i don't know how much you
can do that the way trump did it was the
following
if you don't fix it there is tariffs
if you don't fix it there's more tariffs
if you don't
fix it there's more taxes that got the
attention of people very quickly okay
we're like okay listen let's get this
together
so why don't you say hey mexico if you
don't fix the border issue that
you are causing for us here's a tariff
it's very simple
now i'm just telling you what we're
going to do to you this is the tax you
got to pay us
you still don't want to fix it another
tariff you still don't want to fix it
another tariff do you remember when
trump said mexico is going to pay for
the wall
you know what was the most disappointing
thing that americans were upset about it
what are you upset about it why are you
upset if he makes
mexico pay for the wall what's the big
deal why are you so upset that you're
defending them have
they should pay for the wall we're not
going over their border they should pay
for the wall right
this isn't something where you're look
so let's just say you're president biden
or kamal hairs okay
would you say this is a pretty urgent
issue that's taking place today
is this a pretty urgent issue yes is it
okay is it
how urgent is it right now what's going
on to texas arizona and california
because they're on the border
how urgent it's a pretty big damn issue
it's a pretty big issue that's the
biggest issue
what is the biggest issue number one by
far and away is coveted but kovitz has
already been
solved because we have no what i mean by
that is the fact that we have the uh
what do you call it
we have the vaccine we have some
progress that we're making so it's not
like
we're in the process of making that
better right
what even brings more vex more covet if
you've got hundreds of people
thousands of people that around each
other in different facilities yeah if
covet is your number one why don't you
pay attention to the border a lot of
these people coming over here
a big of course they do that they could
create a bigger
spread i don't know man i i think uh for
me
i like the fact when you say you know
it's been very quiet you know ever since
biden got elected you don't hear a lot
of different problems
yeah i kind of want you to go there asap
and sit down and see what's going on
you're the president man we're paying
you to go do your job and this is an
issue that we're facing right now all
you got to do is get on that air force
one
plane of yours with a few hundred secret
service guys go out there and see what's
going on
make some tough decisions let's move
forward rather than sitting there saying
well
you know i don't know what we're going
to do here if we put too many tariffs
and they're going to say we're doing
what trump did and i want to be compared
to this
forget about it i don't think they're
playing offense to figure out a solution
well you know he's reconsidering to
build the wall
to continue the wall he has no choice
because people are not saying that it
worked
right people are now saying maybe we do
need it so that whole concept about a
wall calling them racist
yeah now people are starting to realize
maybe we do kind of need a wall
the part ricky my challenge is the
following
which there's a part i agree with you
here is which i don't know you may agree
with what i'm going to say but i think
what you're going to say
why are people leaving mexico what can
mexico do what can this do
central american country listen you're
america you know if you're america
impose yep some tariffs go ahead
hey mexico you don't figure this out i'm
not lifting the tariffs
and these tariffs are going to stay for
six months and by
90 days from now if i don't have a
resolution and a report showing me with
what exactly you're doing
guess what we're raising the tariffs
again and within six months
if you haven't done xyz tariffs are
going up again i'm going to put a tier
of tariffs with timelines on them
i'm going to say 90 days by 90 days you
need this between now and then 10
90 days to 180 days if you don't meet
that it goes to 20
180 days to 270 days if you don't meet
that 30 percent
270 days to 365 60 days if you don't
meet that 40
guess what motivates that i want to get
this done because that creates a level
of urgency tied with deadlines let's get
to work we want to help you
we want to be able to accommodate you
but at the same time this is an issue
because you're
you're throwing your problems at us and
we don't want to do that we don't want
to see videos like this this is hard
work you know what's one of the
common things that threads i read here
with people commenting below
parents saying i can't even watch that
video comment if you look at it if
somebody's
saying i can't even watch that video
some of the comments we got juan garcia
gave five dollars he said as a hispanic
parent
so heartbreaking to see those images
jorge ramos is a hispanic puppet for the
left
shout out to ricky for keeping it real
right you're getting people that are
watching this saying this is
this is tough to watch this is not easy
to watch and it's happening and what are
you doing
you're going to different events yeah i
don't know about that that doesn't show
leaders you know what you know what the
most disappointing part about it is
fyi fyi yes pat this doesn't help you
know the whole thing that they're saying
kamala's going to be president
this doesn't help her re-election stuff
go ahead you know what the crazy part
about it is though
it's it's what i'm really disappointed a
lot of my friends are watching this and
are going to watch this
is how many of you guys and i'm gonna
say this to you to my i'm talking about
to my friends
that supported biden how many of you
guys voted for him
because trump was a racist and uh
because that's what they used to to
brainwash you and then on top of that
how quiet you are about what's going on
get it's in our face
it was never this bad our people our
people that carry our
forget about the skincare because i
don't i don't believe in division that
carry our culture
our country right now are literally
going through this and how many people
are quiet about it
i mean it was a daily post trump is
racist trump is racist
wall is racist trump is racist but now
everything's good
because the racist guy is out of the
office according to them
it's just insane to me like it's so
disappointing as a mexican
hardcore i have a centenario on my on my
chest which is the
100th anniversary of mexico it's a coin
they make every 100 years i'm i lived in
mexico
my dad lives in mexico i have property
in mexico i go there often
uh my family's there i just went to
school there i just went and buried my
uncle my grandmother and my uncle
i'm a part of my i'm a mexican citizen i
have a dual citizenship
i'm not a whitewashed mexican that lives
over here watches the news and reads a
couple articles and think they're woke
i i i'm very objective i remember when i
was living there i was 18 years old and
i lived there
i was there for a year one of the times
i lived there
uh we would actually party right with my
friends
that were by the way with families that
are well off that they were going to
cross i remembered vividly
i was there we were at a barn okay i
still remember it's called desvan right
and it's no longer there there's one
and i'm from the truckload which is a
very it's a very dangerous state to be
in right so it's a torment in the cartel
war
and there were three of them were going
to go illegally and we're like getting
on
we're getting drunk the night before
because we're partying for them and they
go up they all three got caught they
came back and we threw a party because
they were back these are not
starving people so when you're sitting
there
and you're a mexican that lived here
your entire life and you
don't you don't even know where your
parents are from and you want to have an
opinion on this
when you don't know what's going on then
there's a stupidest thing ever because
you you let the news rile you up
i was there i saw them leave the town
with well-off families
they just want to go just do something
better go experience another country
it's
it's almost like a vacation to some of i
don't want to say that about all of them
it's unfair for me to
categorize everybody like that but i
know my fair share of people that had no
need to come down here
and they're coming down here and
everybody over here wants to feel bad
because the news is making you feel
better when they're pretty good where
they're at
so you know let's just talk numbers
right now i'm not against immigration by
the way i want you to know
obviously we're immigrants you're
against you're pro-legal immigrants
i'm pro you're not getting raped and
trafficked okay so be very clear upon
that okay
just quick numbers for you while we um
before we move on
um because you brought up you know this
is not a good look for kamala if she's
going to be the
immigration czar um border czar
so let's just talk numbers let's talk
approval ratings biden's approval
ratings
for his handling of covid and the
vaccine 75
that's very insane very high meaning
that he did nothing for it
previous administration created the
vaccine that's the fact sure so own it
so
tell people to get vaccinated then if
you're trump no he didn't i'm just
saying
okay no i'm debating i don't know i'm
gonna just finish my point i'm an
independent thinker
when he when biden came into office
because obviously they were talking
about his plan
when he was campaigning he was saying
this down the other oh we're gonna we're
gonna
put together an action plan and then as
soon as he got elected he said
basically it's just got to run its
course okay there you go
listen let's just talk numbers for a
second his approval rating he just made
a very good point just so you know that
when they asked him i have a plan when i
get elected i'll tell you about it when
he got elected he said we just have to
let her run its course there was no plan
okay yeah but go ahead he's got 77
approval ratings
75 on covet border border patrol uh
situation of the border in the 40s so if
you're looking at numbers and if kamal
is the person that's going to be the
border czar
you can walk and chew gum at the same
time you can handle kovid
and and do well and get vaccinated and
do everything right
but also get kamala's ass down to the
border and make this
situation go away and fix this problem
so i i don't know if the wall
is the solution i think it's more
policies than wall because there's
something called tell me if you're
familiar with this title 42
yes so tell me i don't know i i know
that i'm familiar with the
title 42. i don't know the ins and outs
of it but this is basically a policy
situation
that trump implemented biden came in
with an executive action
and remained and removed it so listen
part of
part of being uh voting for biden or
being a republican is that you can have
tough love
you can love your kids and say bro you
got to do better here your report card
sucks
so my advice to joe and kamala whatever
is
keep doing what you're doing on covid
things are getting better but get your
act together when it comes to the border
because this is a human
a humanitarian disaster but hold on
it's deeper than that the man hasn't
done anything in 42 years
47 years why would you have an
expectation of a vote for a person
that's never done anything
literally you've got a video hold on you
can't say he's never done anything are
you serious
okay you're right massive incarcerated
blacks by the night in the night today
right you're doing it you're right using
the problem again gotta get it no oh
it's probably
or or they're on the books who won the
election
that's that's beside the point we're not
gonna go there no we're not no we're not
i hope you brought cash
no we're not gonna do it no we're not
gonna go there didn't you bring it guys
ricky
we're gonna i believe in you bro we're
not gonna go there we're not gonna go
there
okay no we're not because we're not so
the point is this
here's a reality behind things trump in
his 40s
bron man hand out of ruins that's the
truth when he was in the 30s and 40s
actually brought him in and said what
can we do to fix manhattan he
brought manhattan to where it's at right
what to assert he said hebrew trump
brought manhattan are you serious
they signed meetings they had city
council meetings they had city councils
where he was really helping them rebuild
they said
do this do this do this do this do this
let me build here let me let me build
here he's the one that brought life to
it
right and and that or you'd or am i
wrong if i'm wrong tell me i'm wrong you
don't have to agree with me i don't
think trump was the sole reason
manhattan is what it is okay you don't
think he was the biggest influence for
it
he was the biggest voice at the time i
think he did his fair share but i think
there's a lot of freaking people that
of course i'm not saying that i'd say
rudy giuliani
he's a pioneer right he was a pioneer
for it sure okay
right did our forefathers get the
country to work right now no
the living the forefathers no they
fought for the
to get rid of british and then they
established the constitution and we're
here now but we had to continue
that legacy okay okay that's what i'm
getting at okay so what i'm getting at
is the man has already had previous
success
what is biden done he hasn't done
anything but enforce uh a few laws that
go against mastercard
and then what a kamala hair is actually
known for lock up a brother that was her
nickname
so so why would you have any
expectations for people who have done
nothing for the communities to begin
with
and then expect them to go into office
and want to have expectations for them
it's like having a dog biting you and
then saying don't bite me
it invites you when it's adopted and
then and then you're like don't bite me
when i own this
thing
what's your point my point is why do you
have any expectations you should have
known this happened so it should have
zero expectations for the president of
the united states
why would you if you already knew the
track record no no that's why
you're a smart guy no okay okay okay let
me let me clarify even if your
expectations are low
hold on let me clarify it for you then
let me clarify for you then okay
democrats have voted for him that are
not happy on what he's doing should not
be surprised
you already know he has nothing going on
there's different issues brother no
there's different issues there's covet
there's immigration yeah there's taxes
there's policies she sucks at all of
them don't care tell me one category
he's doing good in
he's doing it in texas covent he's doing
good in kovitz 75
approval rating it doesn't matter what
ignorant people think
the question becomes who started it he
said we gotta let it take its course
trump should get out there and tell
people he already did i started this
thing she did
get your ass back so why do fifty
percent kind of like remember remember
when i was thinking about that someone
was on the podcast and she said
why did what was her name uh uh danielle
she's like
why doesn't the uh what is why doesn't
he uh reject white supremacy i said yes
he did 26 times
remember when i said that okay publicly
he's already publicly saying to do it
so what are you talking about he hasn't
said it more often
he's not the president anymore they took
him off of every single social media let
me ask you do you listen to what trump
has to say
not everything you respect what he has
to say i respect what he is
in certain categories listen ricky yes i
want you to go get vaccinations no sir
i'm an independent i'm an independent
thinker
i don't i don't solely follow one man i
like i could like a lot of what he does
without liking certain things
okay that's what happens when you're an
independent thinker
well played sir so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye